let's talk about another story from the
Daily Mail in this story I was surprised
to see it Mexico uses footage of
homeless people and drug addicts from
Philadelphia in advertisements to scare
young people away from substance abuse
awesome these images are are saddening
now did they bring the the
philadelphians to Mexico to shoot this
or do they go on location to
Philadelphia I think they probably just
pulled the videos from social media from
Kensington probably yeah they just I
mean this is this is insane oh it's
insane it's just completely I think
that's it right there you can just watch
that oh wow here it is hey that nice
production value yeah they're girls
lovely I mean she's cute
oh no she's on drugs in Philadelphia
Street people great account to follow
skateboarding
wait what is this is that this is what
you should be doing is what they're
saying skateboarding not doing drugs in
Philadelphia and they're not wrong and
Mexico is winning with that one well
they don't have any drugs left in Mexico
they're all they're all here but what's
the point of selling them in Mexico and
you can't charge 50 times for them then
you can hear filter the fentanyl from
China through our open border and kill
everybody here I mean that's what people
don't understand is that China has a 50
100 year long memory I mean a 250 year
long memory and a hundred year long plan
and they're still pissed about the Opium
Wars and we don't understand that and
everyone's like why does China keep
sending their fentanyl here and we don't
do anything about it they should be
sending it to the UK I mean we didn't
have anything to do with them you know I
think they should get into the UK
because it's a small island they don't
have a land border to move it but the
thing about what's going on right now in
the United States is that we had the
economy completely just Droid I often
was asking where did everybody go how
come we went to we were in New Market
Virginia last weekend and the restaurant
had a big old white board that said we
are understaffed please be patient
nobody wants to work anymore and then
Ian you actually hit the nail on the
head with the hammer I think when I
started making the joke that people were
raptured you just said I think they're
homeless and then I was like oh my God
yeah actually yeah because
while we're seeing employment collapse
for for lesser skilled and lower skilled
jobs we're seeing homelessness and drug
abuse Skyrocket there's probably a
correlation right it's been happening
quietly
man that's it's only quiet because
they're not they're ignoring it it's
being completely ignored it's you know
it's it's I mean how often do you see
any of this information on but that's
what they want you know in Mexico some
of the cartels have very strict rules
where you can't give fentanyl to the
local population you get punished you
there's retribution in the streets if
you give out the drugs that are supposed
to go up north if you give it out to the
local population because they know the
devastation that it would cause the
local population and how horrible
horrible it would be this is also as of
course there's also a very mirrored uh
history between a lot of the cartels and
American intelligence agencies working
together historically that have been
shipping in things like crack cocaine
and it wouldn't surprise me well it
wasn't in crack form where they shipped
it took it there first yeah yeah well
the CIA taught people how to do this
yeah
that's how the clintons elbow their way
into a CIA family because what people
don't realizes that the Obamas and the
bushes have much more in common than the
clintons and the bushes or the clintons
than anyone else is that those are old
school CIA families like in if you want
to make sorry Mason reference their 33rd
whereas like the clintons are like nine
like the clintons are like down here
elbowing their way up into the higher
level CIA like thinking they're going to
have a legacy they're not and then
there's a big history in Amina Arkansas
that's what I'm saying you know Arkansas
is what happens when um is what Clinton
agreed to run in order to become
president I mean basically there's a lot
of people that think that this is a meme
it says breaking Elon Musk has
reportedly made an offer to buy the FBI
from the clintons oh awesome that's a
good news I think it's like my most like
post too because it has 48 989 likes
just post more memes whenever you post a
meme it's like I get tens of thousands
of likes and I'll post something like
about my life and like everyone's like
Tim we don't care about you yeah yeah
yeah
we're only there for the memes man these
are great this is a good one though this
was this was a good one so yeah I don't
know man when you look at what's
happening with our elections
it it's you know I think a lot of people
are really angry Milo pointed out they
wanted uh Revenge they were hoping that
this would be an absolute National
rebuke of the Democrat failures instead
we were in the same play we got a win
you know that's that's it in the house
and it's not even confirmed just yet and
I'm kind of just like I don't know I was
thinking about what Michael malice was
saying with John fetterman getting
elected and how he wanted him in and I
thought it was kind of funny so you know
the more I think about it this is a
product of absolute collectivism and I'm
very much more on the side of
individualism so my worst case scenario
is we go anarcho libertarian or whatever
it's not my ideal circumstance I know
the anarchists and Libertarians are
probably loving if a system breaks down
and collapses they're going to be
they're going to be living large but I
can I can live with that I can deal with
that if that's what happens you know
what I mean you and my dad have like
that that are like those guys I'm that
guy I'm like this is music to my ears oh
yeah let's do it let's bring Tehran to
the United States I've learned to accept
it and to learn like to embrace the Zen
anarchism like and to even try and
understand what it is like I have I have
only now begun to have like thrive in
the chaos kind of vibe but like uh it
still is I have to say like at the end
of the movie I made it's sad I mean it's
I I was I inherited this country it's
the only thing I would die for if not my
family so I'm not really I don't feel
bad bad being genuine about this like a
lot of these people these days like
after this election like there's a lot
of I won't mention who but there's a lot
of like irony going around where it's
like don't you know elections are fake
anyways like anybody who took this
seriously is dumb and you're like no
actually I I really care about my
country and I don't mind saying so like
it's really important I think what's
also happening here in America with a
lot of these drug overdoses is something
that has been adding to the larger
political shift in this country because
when you look at the opioid epidemic it
predominantly went after Middle America
it went after people that weren't in the
cities people who trusted their doctors
got in a car accident and their doctor
said hey take legalized heroin that
we're gonna cut you off immediately and
now hey now you got to go through Mexico
now you got to go through the cartels
now you gotta go through your local
drugs to get hooked criminalize it and
when you criminalize it you create a
situation where uh of course there is
more harm and more people are dying from
bad drugs more than ever more gang
members are becoming more enriched more
than ever and it's a situation
deliberately created in my opinion meant
to devastate Middle America and this has
been seen as a result of of eliminating
a lot of would-be Republicans
yes and what is the why is that why
would they want to do that because you
will be happy right because people
depended on Government Can you have they
don't want people that are ungovernable
that's why we see authoritarianism in
extremely poor countries because when
you're worried about what to eat and
what you're going to feed your family
you don't have time to have high-minded
philosophical conversations about what
political system you're going to have
and that's the problem with the right
too I was just having a meeting with
somebody earlier today and you're like
like like like we're talking me and this
girl are basically on the complete same
side we're talking about it like we're
on totally opposite complete political
sides we're on the right and it's like
we like take our minds most minute
differences and we make huge issues out
of them and it's like well I can't go
along with this because if of X Y and Z
and it's like that the left doesn't do
that the left is just like they're
coming after abortions go vote
and you're like uh like why can't like
it's like but they don't vote for
anything Democrats vote because someone
knocked on the door and said vote they
went oh good Karen are you in California
no I live in Florida have you started
there you go
from Florida too
it's awesome but incredible but but even
in Florida you do see this this larger
impact of this kind of uh this kind of
destruction of our society have you seen
it in your experiences I mean uh
especially with my son and uh my son 17
and uh uh lives out in the suburbs of
Houston
um and that uh I can tell you the you
know they had they've had a number of
incidents they've had a number of kids
at his school who've all died from
fentanyl overdoses and not because they
knew it was fentanyl because they
thought they were taking an ecstasy
that's right or they thought they were
taking something else because they're
pill pressing these things uh what now
whether they're pill pressing the
fentanyl into these forms and saying
that it's something else and and and not
intentionally putting an overdose amount
in there or intentionally putting an
overdose amount in there I I can't say
for sure but the fact that it's in there
at all is frightening remember when the
U.S government put I think it was
methanol was that in the alcohol
yeah yeah that was a short-lived a
short-lived stun people started dying it
was a short-lived yeah they killed
people the government deliberately
killed people they were violating
prohibition I was here
methanol methanol tell people that you
methanol means you'd be blind I'm pretty
sure or dead uh no but I think that's so
so hold on hold on we'll clarify the you
you what the government was hoping was
that by putting methanol and alcohol
nobody would drink it yeah exactly yeah
and then people drank it and they died
and okay we're gonna stop doing that no
no they wanted a story where people
would die from it they would run with
those headlines seeing see bootlegging's
dangerous you you better not drink the
bootleg alcohol
yeah it literally created uh you know
mafias mafias wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for government
prohibitions wouldn't exist if it wasn't
for them
exactly there you go
I was waiting to argue and I was like
that's actually a good point there
that's a great Point sends ancient Rome
in some form or another but they became
as prominent and as powerful only
because for sure that's what happens no
no the point is the government is a
mafia period there you go and the
they're organized structures like you
know people people uh have this like
um I guess fictionalized view of what a
mafia is where they're like purely
antagonistic to the community and
they're not the same thing is true for
gangs people people that's actually true
gangs are antagonistic in fact when I
when Brazil and Chicago's a really great
example the gangs in Chicago were not
overtly antagonistic we go to the park
and we'd be like oh look there's a bunch
of people from a gang and they were just
a gang and they would do stuff and in
fact they would police their
neighborhoods yeah so when when people
felt like they weren't being protected
and they didn't have the same access as
other people in terms of public
resources or industry they created their
own that's what people do they form
organizations
now some of these people that's what
happens with communities do uh but all
communities do it the difference is the
United States we've we've Mass scaled it
up to the point where it's surrounding
the nation and with military bases all
over the world when I look at uh Brazil
Brazil was a really great example of
this with with the favelas when the
government wasn't active in the shanty
towns The favelas Gangs came up and
became the de facto leadership when the
government realized hey there's tax
money we need to get this stuff we need
to modernize and take control of it they
had to quote unquote pacify meaning they
would go in and rip apart the gangs and
then reassert their dominance over this
area but the gangs were basically just
local government yeah when you say rip
apart you mean they would kill people oh
yeah that's the only way to do it
that's right FBI application rating the
the homes and rating the political
opposition you have to realize that the
FBI is just the gang of the party of the
regime right now they're after the
aliens yeah they're after the UFO guy
yeah I rated today which is absolutely
insane but it's just like a real thing
like yeah it actually happened I want to
talk about this about what the ufci
rating is that the guy who like wrote
Behold a pale horse or something is it
no they took that guy they took that guy
down yeah
that's right I remember addicted 911
that's right yeah that's right what was
that I wrote I read the article where
William Cooper former I read his article
I read his article that uh when it came
out in in 1999 actually uh uh I forget
the magazine that it was in one of these
alternative I thought he died of a wild
card he died in a shootout with police
yeah well in one a One Direction
shootout sort of like Waco
yes Milton William Cooper yeah former
U.S naval intelligence a crazy book that
he wrote the whole house yeah
he died November 5 2001. so that's just
about two months after 9 11. yeah what
does he keep talking about was he like
it's a conspiracy I did not know oh yeah
he was on he was addicted he predicted
it yeah but to what degree like what did
he predict
um you could you I I gotta watch the
video just to make the exact reference
here because I don't want to be very
careful with how I say it but uh do you
remember the exact references yes well
he did on his radio show he he uh he
talked about it and and but it wasn't so
much in the sense that I mean he if I
recall correctly
yeah so did Alex Jones but before Alex
Jones it was William Cooper I believe
yes yeah yeah and there was also we were
talking about Jordan Maxwell earlier
there was another guy who was who was
really on onto all of this stuff and
everything but but that's uh but that
was uh that was pretty shocking but it
was it was in such a way that he didn't
say specifically what happened but you
know I would have to go back and look at
it again thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time